hello
hey how are you good how are you thank
you for doing our 21 questions
um my pleasure so to get started what
did you have for breakfast this morning
i had um banana pancakes
very good let's see how did you travel
to school today
slash how do you usually travel to
school uh usually a drive
drive very cool subaru forester
excellent how long is your journey to
school from door to door
it takes about half an hour 35 minutes
nice what's your mindset when you enter
the school every day
uh when i enter my classroom i always
feel like mr rogers entering his
apartment taking off the shoes always
feel comfortable like it's an extension
of my house
who is your favorite movie star uh meryl
streep who's from new jersey
miles street who is your favorite singer
or band
uh bruce springsteen also from new
jersey
who's your hero my hero is
ruby bridges from new orleans
very cool what's the one place that you
love to visit
i would love to visit it's a tie i want
to go to new zealand
and i would love to go to south africa
new zealand and south africa yeah
what was your favorite subject in school
my favorite subject in school was
science
all right what was your least favorite
subject in school
math sixth grade when we were learning
fractions it was horrible aha
what kind of student were you in school
i was pretty good
when i liked it and i was pretty
horrible and i didn't like it where i
didn't like the t-shirt
favorite cafeteria food all right so
besides pizza fridays
uh they had this chocolate pudding that
was really good
what time do you usually leave school i
usually leave school around
um 4 30. do you usually keep working
once you get home
oh yeah definitely how do you relax
um i absolutely love going to the beach
and i love going in the ocean what are
your passions and hobbies aside teaching
um so one of my favorite things is uh
definitely teacher leadership getting
involved in the profession
what's your proudest achievement as a
teacher i received
the presidential award of excellence in
mathematics and science teaching
if you could write one motivational
quote on your blackboard what would it
be
um a blackboard i had one not that long
ago
i guess it would be give it one more try
and why is that
well because i think i myself have
always given it one more try
and it always leads to more success
and based on that what's the most
important advice that you would give to
your students
i would give to my students that the
best advice would be
if in the course of this year you became
a better person
that would be more important than if you
became a better student and why did you
become a teacher
i wanted to have a bigger impact
with my life and have a sense of purpose
at the end of my work day
where i felt like i was really making a
difference
awesome thank you so much for
participating my pleasure